toute la version de Laurence égal à qui
dit elle est tombée dans l'escalier je
suis arrivé elle était sur le point de
mourir j'ai tenté de la sauver et
évidemment battu en brèche ce n'est plus
qu'une question de jours
mais c'est sans compter un incroyable
coup de théâtre
Lausanne en Suisse le 9 janvier 2010
nous sommes au beau milieu de l'hiver la
nuit est déjà tombée et il fait froid il
est 21h16 lorsque le téléphone retentit
au centre de secours du Samu Suisse le
du standard décroche
à l'autre bout du fil c'est un homme il
est français il s'appelle Laurent Segala
bonsoir 144 les ambulances
oui oui je vous appelle parce que j'ai
trouvé ma mère en bas de l'escalier
j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai pu pour la
ranimer mais j'ai pas réussi à la sauver
mais comment ça elle est décédée
j'ai tout essayé massage cardiaque
bouche-à-bouche tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé ma belle-mère qui qui baigne
dans une flaque de sang j'ai tenté de la
réanimer je crois qu'elle est morte je
sais pas enfin les propos sont décousues
la conversation est très courte
j'ai essayé de la réanimer pendant une
heure en tentant tout ce que je savais
je crois que c'est trop tard
pendant une heure mais vous auriez dû
nous appeler avant
oui mais j'étais pas à côté du téléphone
[Musique]
une pour réanimer cela semble très long
pour le médecin urgentiste
il y a un doute des
incohérences sur le temps que Laurence
et Gala aurait passé à ranimer à tenter
de ranimer la victime
au lieu de d'appeler très vite des
professionnels sur sur ces histoires le
médecin envoie une ambulance mais pas
seulement car face à ce récit qu'elle
juge un cohérent elle passe un autre
coup de fil
elle appelle bien sûr le médecin
urgentiste mais elle appelle aussi la
police
aussitôt alerté policiers et secours se
mettent en route pour le Moulin de veau
sur Morges à l'adresse indiquée par
Laurence Ségala
cette petite commune est située qu'à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de Lausanne
lorsque les secours arrivent sur place
personne pour les accueillir mais il
trouve la porte ouverte la médecin
urgentiste pénètre la première dans la
maison
j'arrive et ils entrent dans dans cette
pièce c'est une antichambre en fait pied
d'un escalier seul l'escalier allumé à
ce moment-là Laurence et Gala descend
Laurence il est un peu hébété ailleurs
un peu à côté de la plaque comme on dit
vulgairement une fois la lumière allumée
le médecin constate qu'en bas des
marches là où serait tombé Catherine
s'égala la belle-mère il n'y a personne
Satan à avoir le corps la victime au
pied de l'escalier est-ce qu'il est ce
qui n'est pas le cas le médecin demande
alors à Laurence Ségala où se trouve
Catherine Ségala l'homme les conduit
dans la pièce voisine
se penche alors sur le corps le constat
est sans appel
dans c'est vraiment pas joli à voir et
il est impossible de tenter quoi que ce
soit pour pour leur animer il est trop
tard
et là le crâne fracassé
elle baigne dans du sang c'est un
spectacle assez épouvantable j'ai vu la
photo du du crâne de
madame Ségala c'est assez impressionnant
selon les premières constatations du
médecin la sexagénaire serait décédée
des suites d'une mort très violente a
priori il s'agirait d'une terrible chute
accidentelle dans l'escalier mais les
policiers eux s'interrogent déjà sur les
circonstances exactes du décès et pour
cause
on constate énormément de plaies alors
est-ce qu'on peut on peut se tuer
effectivement en tombant d'un escalier
mais est-ce que
lhude provoque autant de plaies sur sur
la tête sur le crâne sur le corps ça la
question est toute la question est la
[Musique]
urent ces gala aurait affirmé au secours
que sa belle-mère était tombée sur le
carrelage et avait beaucoup saigné
or le sol est immaculé les policiers
demandent alors une explication aux
Français
qu'il explique lui c'est que il a épongé
parce que il pouvait plus nerveusement
parlant voir tout ce sang Laurence
Séguéla lui explique qu'effectivement il
a la phobie du sang il ne supporte pas
le sang qu'il a tenté de nettoyer la
scène du drame parce qu'il a horreur du
sang les policiers s'est interrogent sur
cette explication pourquoi un homme qui
aurait peur du sang se plongerait-il
dedans pour le nettoyer pour vérifier
les dires de Ségala les policiers
passent la scène au Bluestar ils vont
passer le pied de l'escalier tout le le
l'endroit où Laurence Ségala dit avoir
retrouvé sa belle-mère avec une
substance chimique et ça s'appelle le
bloustar ou le minol qui permet de
révéler des traces de sang des traces de
matériaux organiques disons après
quelques secondes de nombreuses traces
bleus apparaissent les policiers le
savent cela ne peut vouloir dire qu'une
seule chose le carrelage est immaculé de
200 qui a été nettoyé
plusieurs litres de sang peut-être qui
sont qui ont été répondu à cet endroit
là la vieille dame serait donc bien
tombée en bas de l'escalier
autre point qui intrigue les policiers
pour quelles raisons Laurent ces gala
a-t-il déplacé le corps de la victime
encore une fois l'homme a une
explication apparemment logique
d'après des souvenirs de formation de
secouriste
il savait qu'un
quelqu'un qui en choc d'une manière ou
d'une autre à froid il a tenté de la
ranimer sur un sur un
matériau plus plus chaud mais il y a un
autre élément beaucoup plus troublant le
français porte d'étranges marques sur le
visage et une partie du corps
très vite il remarque que que non
seulement c'est Laurence Ségala est très
choquée mais qu'en plus il porte au
visage au cou au début du torse de
nombreuses de nombreuses griffures il a
effectivement
des petites plaies sur le dos des
phalanges et il a des griffures à côté
de l'oreille et sur la lèvre supérieure
d'où viennent ces blessures
Laurence et gala à une réponse il
explique les traces de griffure et de
blessures qu'il a au visage sur le coup
sur les mains il explique ça par qu'il a
voulu déplacer vers la chaufferie durant
une distance d'environ trois mètres
celle-ci la agrippée et lui a fait ses
différentes écorchures et griffures avec
ses bagues etc et ça montre enfin un
dernier détail intrigue les enquêteurs
[Musique]
son pantalon ses chaussures
ses mains sont tachées de sang mais sa
chemise et dans un état correct alors
comment Laurence et Gala a-t-il fait
pour transporter le corps et nettoyer la
flaque de sang sans tacher sa chemise
vous pose la question savoir si il a
changé quelque chose et il explique que
oui il a changé de chemise donc déjà les
policiers commencent à fouiller un peu
dans la maison et il trouve dans un au
pied de la machine à laver ou une
chemise chemise couverte de sang
problème alors que les enquêteurs
fouillent le linge sale
ils font une autre découverte je trouve
pas une seule chemise sachez de sang
mais deux chemises sachent or Laurent
Ségala n'a parlé que d'une d'un seul
changement de vêtements
on retrouve
dans le tambour de la machine à laver
une chemise ma cuillée de sang
pourquoi Laurent Segalen a-t-il rien dit
à propos de cette seconde chemise
sous le coup de l'émotion l'homme ne se
souvient plus très bien de ses faits et
gestes au moment de la découverte du
corps
cette deuxième chemise et même la
première ne sont pas dissimulées ne sont
pas ou détruites ou dénaturés ils sont
pas c'est dans des endroits très faciles
d'accès la deuxième chemise est cachée à
quelques dizaines de centimètres de la
première malgré tout avec deux chemises
ensemble hantées des griffes sur le
corps et le visage et plusieurs litres
de son nettoyé les policiers soupçonnent
leur Ségala d'avoir frappé sa belle-mère
il y a un inspecteur qui lui pose la
question est-ce que vous avez fait une
grosse bêtise et là
l'homme répond
je vous en prie un peu de tenue Laurence
ségalac monte tout de suite sur ses
grands chevaux et qui dit enfin écoutez
un peu de respect et ça ne lui plaît pas
du tout lui il s'est défend bien de
d'avoir
porté le moindre coût sur sur sa
belle-mère il part en garde à vue
[Musique]
avant même de l'interroger au
commissariat les policiers conduisent
Laurence Ségala à l'hôpital pour
l'examiner
[Musique]
sur le chemin de la garde à vue il
conduisent Laurence et gala à l'hôpital
pour des prélever des prélèvements
[Musique]
gardez ce qu'il a sous ses ongles
constater devant médecin les griffures
qui portent au visage et au cou
on le photographie aussi on le
photographie de phase de profil en
photographie c'est balaf c'est griffures
ces hématomes tout ça de manière
scientifique et rigoureuse après avoir
subi ces différentes analyses Laurent
Ségala est conduit au commissariat pour
être auditionné
il est presque 3 heures du matin
[Musique]
quand les policiers demandent à Laurence
et Gala de décliner son identité il
réalise très vite qu'ils n'ont pas à
faire n'importe qui l'homme est un
scientifique de renommer internationale
et a priori il n'a rien du profil d'un
tueur la première chose qu'il voit c'est
que Laurence Ségala c'est un chercheur
du CNRS généticien plus précisément
spécialisé dans les myopathies qui a
passé plusieurs fois à la télévision qui
a fait des livres sur la génétique qui
sont particulièrement
comment
ont été particulièrement remarqués il
est passé chez Frédéric Taddeï
scientifique reconnu Laurence Ségala en
effet participé à cette émission
culturelle c'était un mois jour pour
jour avant le drame la recherche
est-elle dans une impasse fait-on encore
des découvertes importantes on en débat
donc avec Laurence et Gala j'ai des
petits siens directeur de recherche au
stress où vous travaillez sur la
génétique fondamentale et les maladies
génétiques vous pensez qu'on ne fait
plus aucune découverte importante depuis
quelques décennies non il faut pas dire
ça on continue de faire des découvertes
importantes mais et là c'est le citoyen
qui parle papa le chercheur j'ai
l'impression quand même que le pas de la
science art et la
ralenti au cours des dernières années
des dernières décennies
Laurent ces gala est épanoui dans son
travail
[Musique]
et comme en atteste ces archives
personnelles il est également un père de
famille heureux
il a trois filles d'un premier mariage
il vit à tenons avec une compagne dont
il a un enfant
travaillant au CNRS de Lyon Laurence
Ségala a déménagé huit mois plus tôt à
Thonon-les-Bains pour des raisons
familiales son père Roger Jean Ségala
souffre d'une insuffisance cardiaque et
n'est plus à même d'assurer seul la
gestion de sa librairie de livres
anciens une librairie renommée dans
toute l'Europe
[Musique]
son activité professionnelle le domicile
familial est à tenons et il est de son
père à la librairie de Lausanne il avait
décidé de lentement baisser son activité
de scientifiques et à la demande de son
père et de la victime Catherine Ségala
il avait accepté de devenir directeur de
la librairie de livrera de livre anciens
que son père avait mis toute sa vie à
construire retour au commissariat les
enquêteurs demandent à Laurence et Gala
de livrer son emploi du temps le jour du
drame
il raconte qu'il a quitté le matin son
domicile de Thonon les Bains en début de
matinée il apprend que son père Roger
Jean a été victime d'un malaise
cardiaque et qu'il a été hospitalisé
avant de lui rendre visite il aurait
décidé de faire un crochet par la
librairie
[Musique]
suite il allait manger avec Catherine au
moulin entre 13h30 et 14h
au moulin c'est la maison de Roger Jean
et Catherine Segala
ensuite ils sont allés à l'hôpital voir
Roger Laurent Ségala serait resté une
heure sur place avec son père et sa
belle-mère
puis il aurait quitté l'hôpital de
Morges pour se rendre à nouveau à la
librairie où il aurait passé une bonne
partie de l'après-midi Laurent lui a
travaillé à la librairie on sait
qu'il a tort à 17h30 autour de 17h30
il dit avoir eu un client en Suisse et
avoir rangé la librairie
il dira ensuite qu'il est parti vers 18h
18h15 de la librairie pour se rendre à
l'hôpital de Morges où son père était
hospitalisé vers 18h30 Laurence et Gala
retourne donc pour la deuxième fois ce
jour-là à l'hôpital il déclara être
resté à côté de son père 20 à 30 minutes
avant de se rendre à nouveau au moulin
la femme de son père Catherine l'IT
attend pour dîner que lui affirme être
arrivé vers 19h30-20h30 au Vieux Moulin
19h30 20h30 un créneau beaucoup trop
vague pour les policiers il s'interroge
comme on se fait-il que Laurence et Gala
ne se souviennent pas de leur exacte à
laquelle il s'est rendu au Vieux Moulin
la veille au soir
[Musique]
vous savez pas pourquoi vous arrivez pas
à 19h30 ou 19h45 ou 20h ou voilà c'est
quelque chose de plus précis que un
faisceau un créneau du une fenêtre d'une
heure
je porte pas de monde j'aime pas ça j'ai
jamais porté le montre et j'emporterai
pas voilà autre question selon ses dires
Laurent Ségala aurait mis entre 30
minutes et 1h30 pour parcourir les
quatre kilomètres qui séparent l'hôpital
du moulin encore une fois c'est imprécie
mais l'homme a une explication crédible
il dit que les routes étaient enneigées
qu'il a mis du temps pour aller de la
librairie à l'hôpital de Morges de
l'hôpital de Morges à Vaux-sur-Morges au
moulin situation argumentée par le fait
qu'il avait des pneus d'été qui
naissaient beaucoup que la route est pas
plate il y a ça monte ça redescend
qu'il a dû se surprendre à deux trois
fois pour passer dans des dans des coins
[Musique]
et c'est donc en arrivant au moulin
qu'il aurait trouvé sa belle-mère
allongée sur le sol
tout de suite
il découvre
ça sa belle-mère qui vit au bas d'un
escalier extrêmement pentu donc il se
précipite tout de suite pour aller voir
ce qui se passe quand il arrive elle est
encore en vie elle est inconsciente mais
elle est encore en vie le généticien
explique qu'il aurait tenté de réanimer
sa belle-mère et ceux durant près d'une
heure
[Musique]
les policiers lui posent alors une
question essentielle mais pourquoi ne
pas avoir appelé les secours de suite
Laurence Ségala affirme avoir été pris
de panique
il explique que il n'avait pas le numéro
des urgences
vaudoises lui-même est en français qu'il
a dû monter à l'étage chercher
l'annuaire de téléphone pour découvrir
que le 144 était le numéro des urgences
et qu'il le voulait donc pas perdre de
temps un temps précieux dit-il à
chercher ce numéro alors que sa
belle-mère agonisait cette geste
absolument spontané il dit moi j'ai fait
un peu de secourisme moi sa belle-mère
au bas de l'escalier son premier geste
c'est de dire je vais essayer de te la
réanimer on peut pas lui faire le grief
de ne pas avoir téléphoné au secours
c'était soit l'un soit l'autre
après avoir tenté en vain de réanimer
Catherine Segala Laurent appelle les
urgences il est 21h16
après avoir raccroché Laurent raconte
avoir nettoyé le sol cette laver les
mains et le visage et cette changer
avant l'arrivée de secours à 21h50
Laurent Ségala aurait donc tout fait en
moins de 34 minutes
le délai semble court pour les
enquêteurs
d'autant qu'un autre élément les
intrigues
on l'a accusé d'avoir utilisé des
serpillières
et de l'eau de javel en tant que
scientifique il devait connaître le
pouvoir de l'eau de javel de pouvoir
destructeur sur d'éventuelles indices
comme des traces ADN
sur ce point précis Laurent Ségala ne se
souviendrait plus de quels produits il
se serait servi pour nettoyer la mare de
sang
[Musique]
puis moi
je n'étais pas j'étais plus moi-même
j'ai j'avais tenté pendant 45 minutes de
réanimer
celle qui était proche de mon cœur et
j'étais bouleversé en fait une
explication qui ne semble pas convaincre
les enquêteurs
l'explication du comportement de
l'aurait Ségala ce soir-là par
une charge émotionnelle qui doit être
énorme bien sûr les policiers ça c'est
pas c'est pas leur problème
les policiers continuent d'interroger le
suspect mais Laurence Ségala père
patience et se montre de moins en moins
coopératif
cette attitude en permanence il est
arrogant parfois il leur dit votre
question la Nicoli tête il refuse de
répondre à certaines questions il relie
tous les procès-verbaux
de manière très rigoureuse corrige une
virgule précisément et il est vu comme
arrogant hautain sur de lui froid
c'est perçu par les policiers comme
comme des éléments quasiment à charge
laurence est un scientifique qui croit
que toutes les sciences et notamment la
science juridique est une science exacte
je suis une son hostile donc mon
innocence
obligatoirement va éclater au grand jour
et c'est vrai qu'il ne fait pas
véritablement d'efforts pour essayer de
d'accompagner la machine judiciaire
Suisse
après plus de 4 heures d'interrogatoire
l'audition prend fin il est près de 8h
du matin les policiers semblent
convaincus que Laurent Ségala ne leur
dit pas toute la vérité
[Musique]
pas de mobile pas de preuve les
policiers devront miser sur les premiers
résultats des expertises pour confirmer
leur soupes sont
[Musique]
10 janvier 2010 en fin de matinée les
premiers résultats d'autopsie tombe
l'hypothèse de la chute accidentelle ne
serait pas privilégiée les constatations
médico-légales
privilégie très fortement l'intervention
d'un tiers et juge l'état des blessures
incompatibles avec une chute dans les
escaliers la seule chute dans l'escalier
n'explique pas la totalité des
contusions et des plaies que l'on relève
notamment sur le crâne sur le sur le
cuir chevelu
et les médecins légistes vont estimer
qu'il y a eu coût porter à la tête avec
un objet contenant autrement dit
Catherine Ségala aurait été tué de
plusieurs coups assénés sur le crâne les
policiers cherchent alors l'arme du
crime aux environs mais surtout à
l'intérieur de la maison
le résultat des fouilles n'est pas très
probant
[Musique]
dans le moulin on a retrouvé trois
marteaux mais aucun n'a servi aucun
asservi à l'agression aucune trace de
sang sur les outils et pourtant le
rapport d'autopsie est formel un objet
contondant a été utilisé pour tuer à
les médecins légistes
et sur la tête
toute la version de Laurence Ségala qui
dit elle est tombée dans l'escalier je
suis arrivé elle était sur le point de
mourir j'ai tenté de la sauver
est évidemment battu en brèche pour eux
c'est pas plié mais on va quand même
dans un dans un certain scénario qui est
qui se dessine c'est à dire voilà très
clairement un meurtre commis à l'aide
d'un marteau et une tentative de de
nettoyage de la scène de crime
quant aux traces de griffure que
Laurence Ségala portent sur le visage et
sur la poitrine elle serait le signe que
la victime s'est défendue et ils en
veulent pour preuve l'ADN retrouvé sous
les ongles de Catherine Segala
l'ADN est identifié c'est celui de
Laurence
une constatation qui colle parfaitement
avec les griffures que porte le rang
Ségala au torse et au visage alors
évidemment les enquêteurs supposent que
c'est Laurence Séguéla que c'est
peut-être une dispute qui a mal tourné
qu'il y a eu sans doute une lutte entre
les entre les deux protagonistes
en revanche l'autopsie est incapable de
fournir l'heure précise du décès de
Catherine Ségala les légistes estiment
simplement que la mort serait intervenue
entre 15h et 21h
[Musique]
le dossier comporte encore de nombreuses
zones d'ombre toutefois le juge
d'instruction préfère ne prendre aucun
risque Laurent Ségala et français le
meurtre a été commis ensuite après 48
heures de garde à vue le suspect
pourrait être tenté de prendre la fuite
comme il est français et que
Morges comme Lausanne sont au bord du
lac Léman et qui suffit de prendre un
bateau en une demi-heure on est on est
en France et que la France n'extrate pas
ses ressortissants on peut penser que si
on laisse en liberté il ira en France et
en France il reviendra pas en Suisse
Laurent Ségala est donc immédiatement
placé en détention provisoire dans cette
prison dans l'agglomération de mortes et
ce en attendant de nouveaux éléments
un suspect et un seul suspect c'est gala
maintenant on n'a pas de on n'a pas
d'armes du crime on a des blessures qui
sont tout à fait compatibles avec des
coûts portés et on n'a pas de mobile
alors on recherche un mobile
en enquêtant sur la vie du suspect les
policiers constatent que Laurent ces
gala son père Roger Jean et la femme de
ce dernier Catherine ont tous quelque
chose en commun la librairie c'est une
librairie
qui vont beaucoup d'argent avec des
livres rares des livres précieux estimés
environ un à deux millions de francs
autrement dit entre 800 000 et 1 million
et demi d'euros une coquette somme de
quoi attiser les convoitises qui dit
rareté
collection dit intérêts financiers dit
valeurs
donc pour eux il y a quelque chose de
très sérieux à fouiller de très bonnes
raisons de fouiller dans cette direction
et les enquêteurs découvrent justement
que depuis près de huit mois Laurence
Ségala passait de plus en plus de temps
dans la librairie de son père à Lausanne
bien loin de son activité de chercheur
[Musique]
il cherche d'un côté pourquoi il a
déménagé pourquoi il se rapproche de son
père pourquoi il passe beaucoup plus de
temps dans cette librairie est-ce qu'il
y a pas des arrière-pensées derrière
penser prendre l'argent là où il est
effectivement le s'être librairie
représente représente beaucoup d'argent
les policiers s'interrogent avec un père
très malade Laurent Ségala aurait-il pu
simplement vouloir éliminer sa
belle-mère pour toucher le pactole
ils se disent que il y a une valeur non
négligeable à tous ces livres anciens
assez références à et que il a peut-être
intérêt d'une manière ou d'une autre à
faire disparaître et Catherine pour pour
avoir accès à ce que représente
financièrement cette livraie pour en
avoir le cœur net les policiers
auditionnent alors Béatrice masse
accompagne de Laurence et Gala celle-ci
réfute l'hypothèse des enquêteurs le
généticien ne convoitait pas l'argent de
son père
et s'il voulait reprendre la librairie
c'était avec l'accord explicite de
Catherine et Roger
en février 2009 avait été créé une
société à trois avec
Roger Catherine et Laurence ça
permettait de faire un entre deux quand
la libre avant que la librairie passe
complètement à lui pour sa compagne
Laurence et Gala n'était donc pas un
homme intéressé par l'argent une
information confirmée par son supérieur
hiérarchique au CNRS pierre couble
dans sa façon de vivre je ne vois pas ce
qu'il aura amené à être intéressé par
l'argent soudainement ça me paraît ça me
paraît difficile c'est un chercheur au
CNRS donc c'est pas
c'est pas par amour de l'argent qu'on
disait chercheur au CNRS c'est plutôt
pour amour de l'archelle l'amour de la
recherche il a un salaire qui
est conséquent mais relativement modeste
par rapport à ce qu'il aurait pu gagner
dans dans une industrie pharmaceutique
par exemple
reste policiers a interroger la personne
qui peut être reconnaît le mieux le rang
Ségala
son propre père
c'est à l'hôpital que les enquêteurs
suisses rendent visite à Roger Jean
Ségala âgé de 76 ans
bien un caféblis le vieil homme va
défendre son fils avec vigueur
ça ne tient pas votre histoire la
librairie devait lui tomber toute cuite
entre entre les mains j'avais décidé
avec mon épouse de remettre la librairie
à Laurent j'aurais remis le moulin à mes
autres enfants le partage était tout à
fait clair c'est c'est même sa
belle-mère qui a insisté les témoignages
c'est même ça sa belle-mère qui a
insisté pour qu'il reprenne la librairie
elle au contraire va dire à beaucoup de
proches je suis tellement heureuse que
Laurent est accepté de reprendre la
librairie interroger en exclusivité par
le journaliste de presse écrite Arnaud
Beda Roger Jean Ségala affirme que son
fils n'avait aucune raison d'en vouloir
à Catherine bien au contraire
et il s'entendait bien le Laurent était
très affectueux avec pour le père il n'y
a donc aucun doute possible
il explique que les relations entre son
fils et son épouse sont absolument
harmonieuses Aurélia l'une des filles du
généticien va même plus loin Catherine
et Laurent Ségala entretenaient des
relations presque filiales mon père
lui-même il a presque toujours connu
Catherine donc
[Musique]
il me semble et
mon grand-père il s'est mis vite avec
Catherine après que mon père soit né
donc
c'est pas comme sa mère parce qu'il a
une mère mais c'est c'est une personne
de sa famille et au même niveau que son
père
le libraire est formel son fils est
accusé à
tortue
mais en plus il est innocent personne
n'est jamais connu des colères
meurtrières comme ça moi je peux dire
qu'il a jamais été violent que au
contraire c'est une personne très calme
que je l'ai même jamais vu s'énerver
réellement contre quelqu'un c'est au
contraire quelqu'un qui lorsqu'il a des
récriminations va construire son
argumentaire et le dira calmement avec
les mots et il utilisera les mots qu'il
faut mais jamais de façon violente et
spontanée jamais
dans ces conditions comment expliquer le
comportement de Laurence Ségala sur la
scène du drame pourquoi aurait-il
nettoyé la mare de son sur le sol
pourquoi autant d'imprécisions dans son
emploi du temps pour son père il n'y a
rien de mystérieux à tout cela Roger
Jean confirme tout une confirme la
phobie du sang il dit que
fils n'a jamais de montre
il confirme plein de points qui à nous
comme un immortels peuvent paraître
parfois un peu étrange un peu
mystérieuse il confirme tout ça
Roger Jean a même sa petite idée sur ce
qui a pu se passer au moulin ce fameux 9
janvier Catherine a pu tomber née à nez
avec des cambrioleurs
que la maison était fermée a pu repérer
et
lui sauter dessus
pour voler mais ensuite bon
dérangé ou on ne sait pas quoi c'est
vraisemblable c'est une c'est très isolé
la piste paraît plausible car de sources
policières comme l'indique cette carte
plus de 40 cambriolages ont été commis
dans un rayon de 30 km autour de Morges
la seule semaine de la mort de Catherine
Segala il y a eu un gang de chirurgiens
sur la Suisse qui ont commis énormément
de cambriolages y compris dans cette
région et y compris à vaut sûrement
cambrioleur surpris c'est une hypothèse
c'est arrivé dans dans la région deux
ans plus tôt avec le décès de d'une
personne qui a surpreneur chez elle
c'est pas tout à fait c'est plausible
seul problème en effectuant une
perquisition le soir du drame les
policiers n'ont remarqué aucune trace de
cambriolage
rien n'a disparu de la maison tout est
là l'argent est là
il n'y a aucune trace d'effraction
aucune trace de pas qui repart de la
maison à travers les champs alentours il
y a pas de de d'empreinte digitales ou
génétique qui appartiendrait à un tiers
mystérieux
[Musique]
ce test du cambriolage ou du d'un rôdeur
et rapidement rapidement écarté la piste
du cambriolage écarté pour les
enquêteurs Laurent Ségala est toujours
suspect dans cette affaire
[Musique]
une volonté dans on sent dans le canton
de Vaud d'avoir on a trouvé un coupable
et on veut que ça soit lui le coupable
il reste qu'après six semaines d'enquête
les policiers n'ont toujours pas réussi
à établir le mobile du crime un témoin
inattendu va pourtant faire une
révélation fracassante
24 février 2009 commissariat de Lausanne
une certaine barbarassée une des
meilleures amies de Catherine Segala
demande à parler aux enquêteurs une amie
de Catherine qui approche les policiers
vos doigts et qu'il le raconte que
quelques jours à peine fin décembre
quelques jours à peine avant sa mort
Catherine lui a fait part de certains
soucis et de certains doutes qu'elle
avait
contre Laurent
le soupçonnait de piquer dans la caisse
en gros vu qu'une librairie de livres
anciens il y a beaucoup de cash qui
circulent à en croire ce témoignage les
relations entre Laurence Ségala et
Catherine étaient loin d'être parfaite
les policiers élaborent alors une
nouvelle hypothèse
on pourrait imaginer un scénario que
Catherine se rend compte de cela sous
soupçonne Laurent de piquer dans l'astre
dans la caisse sans doute des sommes pas
très importantes quelques centaines de
francs et qu'elle veut crever l'abstacle
elle veut lui en parler
ça tourne mal
on s'énerve de part et d'autre et puis
voilà on en vient au point et à la
dispute à la bagarre et
Catherine se retrouve précipitée en bas
des escaliers pour les enquêteurs ce
témoignage est capital s'il est avéré
les policiers tiendraient enfin le
mobile du meurtrier présumé encore
faut-il pouvoir élaborer la chronologie
des faits avec précision
lors de son audition le généticien a
affirmé avoir quitté la librairie vers
18h15
pour rendre visite à son père vers 18h45
il serait reparti vers 19h15
au final Laurent Ségala serait donc
arrivé chez Catherine entre 19h30 et
20h30 un emploi du temps que les
policiers vont s'attacher à vérifier
minute par minute
[Musique]
il y a de la neige il n'a pas de pneus
neige le moulin est à 4 km
on peut lui attribuer une demi-heure
pour faire les quatre kilomètres son
pneuses sur la route toujours selon la
version des enquêteurs Laurent Ségala
serait donc arrivé au moulin chez
Catherine entre 18h30 et 19h il y aurait
donc pour les policiers à un trou dans
son emploi du temps inexpliqué entre 19h
et 21h16 il appelle les secours à 21h16
que s'est-il passé pendant ces deux
heures et pourquoi est-ce que deux
heures s'écoule avant qu'il appelle les
secours
Laurence Ségala a bien une explication à
apporter il affirme que même s'il a
éteint son ordinateur à 17h30 à la
librairie il est parti bien longtemps
après
Laurence pas du tout j'ai eu encore un
client au moment où je m'apprêtais à
partir un client est entré dans la
librairie
m'a acheté un livre on a encore bavarder
un moment et je suis resté en tout cas
une demi-heure 45 minutes dans la
librairie pour pouvoir m'occuper de ce
client
alors il se souvient pas du nom de
l'acheteur ni du titre du livre
la transaction ce serait faite en
liquide
la famille de Laurent Ségala va alors
s'employer à trouver ce fameux client
qui constituerait un véritable alibi
la défense de Laurence Ségala est allé
très très loin vu que la même lancée un
appel dans la presse locale pour
retrouver le client de cette librairie
qui est donc ce mystérieux client qui
est entré dans la librairie le 9
décembre à 17h30 pour acheter un livre
l'appel à témoin publié les proches de
Laurence Ségala ont bon espoir s'il
retrouve l'acheteur le généticien de
bonnes chances d'être innocenté
seulement les jours passent et personne
ne répond malgré l'appel lancée dans la
presse aucune personne ne se manifestera
auprès des policiers
une explication pourrait être qu'il
devenait d'ailleurs que l'appel à
témoins a été diffusée finalement dans
la région alors que cette personne peut
ne pas l'avoir entendu les policiers
s'interrogent sur l'existence réelle de
ce mystérieux client
l'affaire étant passe d’être bouclée ce
n'est plus qu'une question de jours
mais c'est sans compter un incroyable
coup de théâtre
la famille de Laurent Ségala n'a pas dit
son dernier mot elle conteste le premier
rapport d'autopsie et commande une
contre-expertise médicale mais pas à
n'importe qui
au professeur Dominique Leconte c'est la
directrice de la City médical de Paris
c'est une dame qui s'est occupée de très
très grosses affaires de Lady Diana de
la faire Trintignant Cantha de
la faire Borel de la faire ordre Sart
c'est une femme donc une certaine
notoriété et après dès semaine d'analyse
ses conclusions sont saisissants pour
elle
ce que l'on constate sur le crâne de
Catherine Ségala
peut-être dû uniquement à la chute dans
l'escalier
or
jusqu'au moment où le professeur le
compte publie son rapport
beaucoup avaient porté sur les fameux
coup sur la tête que le rapport de Toxie
le premier
percevait la médecin légiste française
est formelle Catherine Ségala n'aurait
pas été assassiné elle aurait été
victime d'un malaise cardiaque
un malaise initial cardiaque a pu être
causé par la situation de stress et
d'extrême fatigue de la victime et être
à l'origine d'une chute dans l'escalier
une chute dans l'escalier une chute qui
aurait entraînée la mort de Catherine
Segala l'histoire se raconte alors de
manière totalement différente madame
Ségala
que qu'elle est rentrée chez elle au
bout d'une journée assez pénible je
crois qu'elle avait conduit seul depuis
l'Italie avec son mari malade qu'il a
fallu hospitaliser
il y avait des sérieux éléments pour
qu'elle fasse un malaise Catherine
Segala est en haut de l'escalier toute
seule au moulin à une heure où Laurence
Ségala est à la librairie elle est prise
dans malaise cardiaque
elle tombe dans l'escalier sa tête
heurte plusieurs marches et notamment
une marche en béton ébréchée qui va lui
trancher le cuir chevelu ce rapport
c'est un coup de tonnerre dans une
enquête qui pour l'instant
s'oriente depuis le premier jour vers
une thèse criminelle de manière certaine
à partir de cette version ce que dit
Laurence et gala est tout à fait
plausible il a le tort de ne pas appeler
les secours mais il essaye de la ranimer
quand il arrive au moulin et qu'il voit
sa belle-mère à l'agonie dernière
information essentielle de ce rapport
d'expertise français l'horaire de la
mort de Catherine Ségala là encore
l'analyse innocentrée le généticien
[Musique]
examen de la fonction gastrique à
l'appui la première thèse évoque l'heure
du décès entre 15h et 21h cette deuxième
exercice privée évoquait un horaire
beaucoup plus précis puisqu'elle situe
l'heure du décès entre 15h30 et 17h et
il est avéré qu'à cette heure-là le
suspect est à la librairie à en croire
cette contre-expertise Catherine Ségala
serait donc déjà morte ou dans un coma
profond quand Laurent est arrivé au
moulin de veau avec de telles
conclusions le rapport le compte fait
l'effet d'une bombe il dédoit non
entièrement Laurent ces gala mais pour
la partie civile il y a un problème ce
rapport a été commandé par la défense et
ce à titre privé
c'est à dire que on essaie de demander
un expert écoutez pour nous la seule
explication dans cette affaire malgré
malgré tous les éléments qui qui
incarnent notre client
c'est qu'il doit s'agir d'un pouvez-vous
pouvez-vous en analysant tout ça pour
pouvez-vous accréditer une telle thèse
le procureur est face à un dilemme un
rapport suisuit sacréditant la thèse de
l'homicide ou un rapport français qui
conclut à l'accident alors qui croire la
justice et le verte n'a d'autre choix
que de commander un troisième rapport
septembre 2011 dernier rebondissements
de cette affaire qui passionne la Suisse
les résultats de la troisième et
dernière expertise demandez cette fois
par le procureur du canton de Vaud les
conclusions du spécialiste Duarte nous
nos Vieira un médecin portugais qui fait
lui aussi autorité en matière criminelle
sont en contradiction avec le précédent
rapport voici en substance ce qu'il dit
elle n'est pas tombée uniquement elle
n'est pas morte en tombant de l'escalier
il y a bien eu ensuite une agression une
agression qui aurait été réalisée à
l'aide d'un objet contondant par exemple
un marteau même si les médecins ne
peuvent l'affirmer
[Musique]
deuxième élément balayé par le légiste
portugais Catherine Ségala ne serait pas
morte d'une crise cardiaque et lors du
décès serait impossible à définir avec
précision
ce troisième rapport vient balayer les
conclusions du professeur Lecomte de
quoi susciter la controverse
lui va rendre un rapport où il va passer
au vitriol au karcher le rapport de
Dominique Leconte on peut s'étonner qui
est qui est certain commentaire qui
laisse entendre que Laurent Ségala est
un individu très intelligent et un but
lui-même etc ce qui est un peu curieux
parce qu'on lui demandait pas ça on lui
demande d'où viennent les blessures pour
la ligne pour l'accusation Laurence
Ségala serait coupable et ce pour
plusieurs raisons
deux rapports de médecins légistes
conclus à l'homicide
un emploi du temps selon les enquêteurs
non justifiés pendant deux heures
des traces ADN de Laurent Ségala
retrouvé sous les ongles de la victime
enfin pour la partie civile l'argument
selon lequel Laurent Ségala n'a pas le
profil d'un tueur ne tient pas
l'habit ne fait pas toujours le moi en
matière de justice Vous avez des gens
qui ont assassiné violé en série à qui
vous auriez confié vos enfants sans la
moindre réticence et puis d'autres
inversement qui ont un profil en
comportement de coupain mais pouvant
elles font très mauvaise impressions ils
sont des gens qui qui n'ont jamais
commis ne serait-ce qu'un vol à la
roulotte
mais pour la défense il n'y a aucune
preuve contre Laurence Ségala pas
d'armes de crime pas de mobile il n'y a
qu'un seul témoin à charge Barbara C
mais pour les proches de l'accusé ce
témoignage est douteux Laurent Ségala
Lou est à Lausanne un studio appartenant
à Barbara c'est hors propriétaire et
locataires étaient en conflit depuis
plusieurs semaines
Laurent lui est en frileux c'était
l'hiver
il chauffait pendant qu'il n'était pas
là pour que quand il rentre il fasse
chaud et cette dame ça ne lui plaisait
pas elle venait baisser le chauffage
bref il y a eu des mots donc on va
vraiment que c'est un problème de
conflit personnel enfin de conflits
entre eux on peut s'étonner qu'on
attache une importance
aussi importante à une dame qui est
marginale dans cette affaire
parce qu'elle était moins de rien du
tout si ce n'est qu'elle n'apprécie pas
bon
sans preuve ni mobile contre leur client
les avocats de Laurence Ségala
s'appuient principalement sur les
conclusions du rapport du professeur
Lecomte pour eux les griffures seraient
bien le résultat du transport du corps
et surtout il soutiennent que Catherine
Segala serait morte des suites d'un
malaise cardiaque dans l'après-midi
alors que Laurent était encore à la
librairie
le procès de Laurent Ségala devrait se
tenir durant le premier semestre 2012
les jurés auront alors la lourde tâche
de décider si le généticien et le
coupable ou un innocent qui a juste
succombé à la panique
[Musique]
on peut être innocent avoir la phobie du
sang tout faire en début en dépit du bon
sens ne pas appeler les secours pendant
une aussi longue période
et n'avoir rien à se reprocher
en attendant son jugement Laurence
Ségala est toujours en détention
provisoire en Suisse
[Musique]